P I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor in a
result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 person went to executive
order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the committee
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporary music listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for the
this meeting complies with house rules
at RSA
91a anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS leg. state. n.
Us in the event the public is on un able
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote we'll start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member stays their
present please also State whe whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
under the right to know
Mr representative alleo present in the
room representative Bailey present in
the room represent Ed
alone
representative I am present I'm home in
uh at my home and my wife is in the
house as well representative goie I am
room representative
Gro home in my present home in my office
alone representative
JY I'm
hospital
hospital hope for the best thank you
representative
lonara I'll be Mobile today in nashv uh
there may be people
around representative laus pres in the
committee room representative MCU pres
O'Brien representative of Brian Glen
T we'll wait for him I guess
representative Pearson I'm sorry
representative O'Brien is here he seems
okay
uh I come back to
him representative
Pearson representative Pearson's here
I'm in Manchester
today representative Bry here in the
committee room representative
saso I'm here alone in ke
Hampshire representative
Schmidt I am president in my home office
in do and I am alone representative
Shu representative Shu reporting in from
her home in pimbrook
president accounted for representative
Schultz I am at my residence in
conquered my husband Jee Taylor will be
in and out of the room thank you the
clerk is here in the room and
representative
yakovich no ST not here yet I guess
going back to representative O'Brien
have you
unmuted uh thank you for getting back to
me I'm present I'm at home in nashar and
I got grandkids all over the place thank
you okay okay representative McGuire
everyone is here I except for yakob bich
point all right thank you he was
traveling
see all right in any
event we'll open the hearing on Senate
Bill 20 1 and I call the prime sponsor
Senator
Sherman thank you madam chair can you
hear me
yes um thank you for the record my name
is Senator Tom Sherman I represent
District 24 which is 11 towns on the Sea
Coast um and I'm introducing
sb21 it's a very straightforward
correction of Statute uh and this story
is that in
2019 the Greenland house delegation
brought forward HB
243 which would have added uh an
additional member to the peas
Development Authority uh board of
directors um that would have actually it
it would have meant changing the size of
the board and was felt by the board to
potentially be somewhat
disruptive and in in a compromise on the
Senate side we were able to agree to
Portsmouth giving up half of a
representative and letting Greenland
have that half so rather than changing
the size of the PDA board it simply um
replaced one half of portsmouth's
representation and so there would be a
shared representative from Newington and
Greenland
unfortunately uh and it wasn't caught
until the governor was about to sign the
bill uh in redrafting with the amendment
the original language of the bill that
changed the size of the PDA board and
the subsequent
Quorum um was not eliminated from the
the bill so with the understanding that
we would be filing the correction in
20120 the governor went ahead and signed
the bill the effective date of the
original
bill um is not until next month uh which
is April 30th
2021 so nothing was going to happen to
the peas Development Authority board
until the end of April of this
year uh and so I filed SB
592 uh last year which was a victim of
covid it was uh of course felt to be
very important because we had to correct
that Quorum requirement otherwise the
board would not be able to
function
um when it was tabled it was then
incorporated into one of the Omnibus
bills and you may remember I can't
remember the exact number of that
Omnibus Bill but it was massive and it
was all administrative Corrections uh
and it was
vetoed um so we are left still needing
to make that simple correction this is a
very very short bill um it makes the
correction in the Quorum requirement by
repealing the part of the bill from 2019
that should not have been in there um as
uh you and I have discussed Madam chair
that the uh Senate expedited this with a
goal of trying to get this in front of
the governor before the end of April so
that uh the quum require M will not
impact the board in any kind of negative
way so I would appreciate the support of
the committee um and expedited executive
action so that this could go uh to the
full um to the Full House and to the
governor's desk uh with a goal of
getting it there before the original
Bill had any impact and um I'm happy to
take any questions if there are
any thank you senator are there any
questions from the
committee representative
fellows thank you madam chair um Senator
I'm looking at the
RSA as it stands right now and you you
mentioned that the bill was originally
at the request of
Greenland but that they're not
mentioned as a member are is that the
member that's nominated by the majority
vote the legislative delegation of
straford
County uh let me look
back at uh the
bill yes uh in the original bill which
was 256 that has been
Incorporated you'll see uh now in the
RSA under
Section
2561 Roman
1 uh f
one member appointed jointly by the
board of Selectmen of the town of
Greenland and the board of selectman of
the town of
Newington representative fellows it may
not be in the RSA you're looking at
because the effective date is not until
the end of next month right I was
I
it's it is actually the RSA on the State
website with the note at the end saying
it effective
until representative leus reports that
the State website
statute you were garbled Madam chair
could you repeat that I'm sorry rep leus
reports that the State website includes
both versions of that piece of Statute
with a note of the effective date when
one changes to the other
thank you that came through loud and
clear very good representative Schmidt
do you have a question well I just
wanted to say as chairman of the
straford county delegation which does
nominate uh one member of the board I
can confirm that uh that this is uh not
responsibility um I'm sorry not part of
whose responsibility to do what the the
Strafford County delegation had has one
nomination uh for a member of the board
of uh peace Development Authority but we
have no involvement with the issue in
question thank you are there any other
questions for Senator Senator
Sherman all right seeing none thank you
Senator thank you very
much is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate Bill 21 please raise
do all right seeing none I will close
the public hearing on Senate B
[Music]
21 someone here to make a motion yes I'd
like to move uh on to pass for Senate
Bill 21 second by representative Schmidt
all right you should speak to your M I
think we just uh had the discussion we
needed I mean this is a correction that
is time critical and we should move
forward with it thank you representative
Schmidt do you wish to speak no that
remark was entirely Uno and
satisfactory excellent glad CH yes
who who made the motion representative
leus thank you all we could see that it
was coming from the committee room thank
that's all right any uh further
discussion on on the motion or on the
bill representative
Bailey no you're not
making questions
comments all right in that case the
motion is thought to pass on Senate Bill
21 and the clerk will call the
yes yes representative Pearson
yes representative
yakovich not president uh representative
leus yes representative Alro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
lonar yes
representative
[Music]
saso he was here a minute ago he's there
I
yeah representative goie yes
representative
sh
yes
representative repres JY
we representative schmith
yes representative Schultz yes
yes representative fno yes
representative Roa
yes representative
O'Brian yes and the chair
yes looks like 18 to zero does anyone
consent right seeing none we'll put it
on consent and representative leus if
you could have a A or at your very
earliest convenience I would appreciate
fine I was expecting this to take a
little
longer
in that case why don't we move on
to House Bill
417 and I'd like to move or to pass and
I present Amendment
correct I believe this was distributed
to everyone yesterday it incorporates
the changes that were pointed out as
necessary on
Monday
um you'll notice on page one on line 15
it talks
it starts
the uh automatic extension if the
legislature is unable to
convene as
page there that goes there and if you go
on to page two line 15 is a new
paragraph that requires the
uh the fiscal committee to be involved
according to normal procedures if the
$100,000 also extra
[Music]
question are there any uh questions
discussion yes I wish to be heard
okay representative goalie got there
first and then representative Schmidt
thank you madam
chair represent goalie thank you madam
chair uh I will be supporting this
amendment
um well I don't believe we really needed
to touch the uh Governor's declared
state of emergency portion because it
could be um removed at any time with a
house concur with a concurrent
resolution um I think this is a a good
compromise knowing that
um executive order should be the balance
of power should be in check with the
governor's executive orders um during a
state of emergency and um by extending
uh the state of emergency out to 30 days
it makes it more
reasonable um also I think it's very
important that the fiscal committee have
a look and they say on how money coming
in uh is spent especially as we saw in
pandemic uh tens of millions of dollars
coming into the state um I believe the
uh joint fiscal committee should be
looking at those dollars and uh making
sure they're spent wisely uh so with
these changes I I will uh support the
amendment thank you thank you
representative
Schmidt thank you madam
chair um as I have said before and I
continue to assert uh this is premature
we are not going to be um affecting the
current situation which is the cause of
the con of the consternation on the part
of some portion of our
population uh and it it a 30-day renewal
process is um sounds workable but in in
many cases uh it won't be necessary uh
because most emergencies are quite time
Limited and either Regional or local and
uh it this would be unnecessary in in
those types of situations uh to call the
legislature in to renew it because it's
going to take another week or 10 days is
a waste of everyone's effort time and
and expense H and uh in the case of a
situation such as we currently face or
in Thea event of a potential nuclear
emergency at seab Brook um the the time
frame would be uh uh unknowable in
length uh and uh what we should be doing
is retaining this this bill to work on
it uh because I don't think that this
methodology is workable or necessary in
most circumstances and and unworkable in
a true emergency of the nature we
currently confront so I'll be voting no
um and opposing it on the house floor as
well thank you
thank you uh representative font
now thank you madam chair um I guess
excuse my ignorance or inexperience on
this I'm just trying to clarify on the
page two paragraph 15 uh regarding
acceptance of any federal uh private or
other Grant and exceeds $100,000 does
this also
clarify
that uh Finance
committee a fiscal
committee approval for expenditures of
those funds after they've been that
represent font no that is in RSA 1430 D
Roman 6 it's part of their normal
procedure um so it doesn't need to be
specified here thank
you okay representative
legro we're sitting smack in the middle
of precedent that that's pertinent to
this bill so to suggest that it's not
needed because most
emergencies won't require the measures
in this bill I I don't understand so I
will be supporting this
bill uh in light of possibility of
future emergencies similar to this
one thank you anyone else I'd like to
say something that the the the reason
that we can the reason that the initial
state of emergency is extended to 30
days rather than 21 is to make sure that
we don't get involved in the sort of
routine weather related emergencies we
don't need to be involved we don't want
to be involved and it and they're almost
entirely over by 30 days um so I think
we can that addresses that issue and
regard to not necessary this is the
first emergency that has required this
sort of extensions and what it did is
that it showed some of the weaknesses in
the current statute that that allows the
governor to accept hundreds of millions
of dollars with no
oversight all right so that's that's a
concern some of the executive orders
were felt by many people as excessive
and there was no oversight so all all
that the legislature had was the blunt
Hammer of saying we'll end the state of
emergency and that was not not feasible
we could have done it when we met in May
and June but would it wouldn't have been
effective because most people felt that
we were in emergency what no matter how
many of the executive orders they
disagreed with they couldn't say there
was no emergency at that time so this
gives the legislature the policymaking
form of government the authority to be
more nuanced and deal with the executive
orders one at a time rather than you
know just totally in the state of
emergency and so I think this is a good
start we have already retained House
Bill
275 to see if there are other issues
that need to be addressed this simply
deals with the
issue of
oversight okay we have some more
comments representative
Shu oh
s represent
sh yes I'm looking for my unmute thank
you um yes I just wanted to um point out
to representative fontel that at our
previous discussion of the former
Amendment proposed to this bill we had
asked for for just a cross reference to
that statute for the fiscal committee
out thank you representative Roy thank
you madam chair
um the reason I I crafted this build the
primary U purpose for it or at least
driving factor of me was my inability to
answer my constituents as to what was
going on
um you know the governor passed a lot of
orders some people agreed some people
disagree that's really here nor there
for this but the problem was is lack of
communication I don't know about the
rest of you but I found out about a lot
of these things the same way my
constituents did um when it came out in
the news and they would call me or write
me and say hey what's what's this about
and I'd have to say I have no idea um
now as this goes on for a year you know
30 days it is what it is but when we get
into six seven eight nine months and all
I can say is I don't know um that's not
my job as a representative to represent
the people in government we have to be
able to at least give them answers and
know what is going on um having
oversight is even better but just as a
starting point to be able to answer my
constituents what is happening to them
and why to me is of utmost importance so
fellows thank you madam chair I I have I
just would like a clarification and it's
about the um the change that's on the
first page so what would happen if the
the house and the Senate
met but in one
chamber you know voted in the majority
to are they supposed to vote to continue
or
to um terminate and this they can vote
to
under this amendment representative
fellows the vote is to continue the
state of emergency and if either house
voted no it would not
continue thank you that was what I was
trying to figure
out representative lacus yes following
on to what representative Roy said
um after the 30 days that the
legislature gets involved in reviewing
the executive orders even even if the
legislature approves every one of them
at least they are representing their
constituents and you know having
presumably people will come and testify
and there'll be a possibility for um the
public to comment on them uh you know
the one for meeting like any other
hearing Le that's a possibility and the
legislature has an I think an
obligation
as to be involved in the process and
represent the people and we haven't been
year anyone
else I just might mention to
representative Schmidt that I would not
let the perfect be the enemy of the good
in this case as the chair has pointed
out we're retaining a bill that can
amend uh or address concerns that you
might think of in the mean uh so I've
listened to what you said and that's my
thought about it thank you
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well first
of all I I want to state that I concur
with uh several of the previous speakers
that uh the the handling of this pre
present situation has not been uh
without flaws uh and the the
disregarding of the joint fiscal
committee
uh rightful uh involvement in the
dispersement of funds acceptance of
funds and so forth is a particularly
egregious example of that a number of
the executive orders that the governor
has issued uh also have caused a lot of
consternation uh among a lot of us uh
because of the lack of transparency and
so forth so I don't dispute that there
is cause for the legislature to uh to
look into this but but th this bill will
not impact the current situation where
the governor has acted uh somewhat
high-handedly in my opinion uh and I I
absolutely agree that the legislature
should be involved in amending the
current statutory situation it's just
that this bill does nothing to curb the
governor's uh potential abuse of uh of
his powers uh in the current
circumstance um and there for uh it it
does not remedy the the the current
situation uh and it's unlikely that we
could pass a bill that would do that uh
under the
circumstances so I'm all in favor of
making a number of changes but I would
like to get much more involvement of
other committees uh and the other body
and so forth uh so I'm I'm not hostile
to any of those objectives it's just a
we don't accomplish it with this bill um
and some of the current C some of the
current fixes uh I think are not that
workable and they they deserve further
deliberation and greater involvement
than we can give it under these current
time constraints so I respect my
colleagues positions on this but but I
think that uh that this bill is um is
not not that workable uh and it doesn't
resolve the current problems with the
governor's maintenance of his of his
Vera thank you madam chair I think that
this is a good
start and I'll be supporting this
amendment um I particularly like the
fact that if we can't meet the executive
orders continues in 14 day 14-day
increment which seems to me very
reasonable um I do like the um well like
is not the right word I support the um
involvement of the
legislature actually the governor's
Council in um the fiscal responsibility
that the governor has when it comes to
um accepting
money and um I do like the fact that um
if um in every place that there's
legislative
a contingency if we can't meet so I
think that this is an improvement of
what we had we didn't know what we we
really didn't know what we needed until
we were put in this
position and now we have something to
use hopefully we won't need to use it
but it will give us a um it'll give us
more guidance than what we have now so I
appreciate the bill the amendment and I
will support it thank you representative
laus and then representative
fellos um so I'd like to address repres
the first point representative Schmidt
brought up um and I have to agree with
him uh entirely I would like to see
something done to get the legislature
more involved now um I think the effect
date of this was selected because there
were concerns the governor would veto a
bill that interfered with the current
state of emergency if that weren't an
issue I would certainly uh you know want
the uh effective date to be up fun
passage so at this point there's nothing
we can do about the current state of
emergency unless we're willing to
support um hcr2 which would completely
end it but that's a separate
discussion and as the second point I
don't see why it's not working I mean
there could
be you know if you think about what's
happened over the last year there were
certainly periods where the
legislature you know maybe it could have
met maybe not but you some of the times
given the knowledge of the time we
probably would not have met we probably
would have thought we could not meet and
this deals with that I mean you know
emergency could be extended if the
governor wanted 14 days at a time but so
I mean but we have met over the last
year so certainly there were
opportunities for the legislature to
review and either approve or not
approve um you know the emergency orders
and you know if this was had been in
place if nothing else I think the
governor would have had more open
discussions with the legislature about
what he wanted to do because you know we
would have had the ability to
um we would have actually had to approve
if we to meet the emergency orders and
he would have known that and I think
there would have been uh you know more
discussion and more feedback you know
whether or not we actually chose to meet
you know or not
so while Surly there there could be
circumstances we could meet and that
don't anticipates it I don't see if the
unworkable representative
fellows I'm I'm okay I had put my hand
down
amendment all right in that case the
motion is to adopt Amendment
yes yes representative
pearon
yes
[Music]
yich no
V representative leus yes representative
mroo yes representative Bailey yes
representative
Lara yes representative
saso yes representative goalie yes
representative
Judy we
week uh you garble I if you said my name
no I representative Schultz yes
representative
Fells yes
Representative
no
yes representative groa
yes representative
O'Brien yes and the chair yes 17
adopted representative Roy moves ought
to pass with Amendment I'll second
leus do you wish to speak to your motion
repesent no I think we is that all
say like us I
agree all right since the it's probably
because the amendment replaces the
entire
Bill all right um in that case anyone
else wish to
speak Adam chair I will just say thank
you for making it clear who's making the
motions GL to help representative
Schmid thank you madam chair uh one
aspect that I did not address in the uh
remarks on the amendment is that uh
we've had uh to my knowledge no input
from the governor's office uh or from
the other body or from uh the public uh
so given the fact that we are not
changing the current situation at all um
this is premature and we should go at
this hammer and tongues because uh I the
fact that that the bill might have a
number of very good Provisions in it and
I agree with them um I still think the
workability issue it's like a a table
that has three good legs and one bad leg
the fact that the three good legs are
are fine won't keep the taable standing
up if there if the bad leg fails so
there there doesn't have to be a total
unworkability in order for the bill to
not be functional and and I think we
need more involvement for more people
and more expertise in order to come up
with all the changes that need to be
made and therefore I will vote against
the bill as amended uh for the same
reason I oppose the
amendment thank
speak okay then the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 417
the clerk will call the
0973 representative Roy
yes CL folks yes representative Pearson
yes representative yovich well wasn't
question representative leus yes
representative Alro yes representative
Bailey yes representative Lara yes
representative Santo
Vaso yes representative goie yes
representative
Judy we says
yes
representative Schmid no representative
Schultz
no representative
fno
yes representative broen yes
representative
O'Brian
yes chair yes
uh
[Music]
16-2 all right uh repres is
there Madam chair you did not raise the
issue of the consent calendar but I
object to consent I was asking already
representative Schmidt if there was
going to be a Minority
Report I Ament as well I will write a
Minority Report all right oh thank you
we will put it on the rular calendar and
representative Schmid will write a
Minority Report all right thank you all
and I am truly impressed with the timing
we have a minute and a half before half
a minute before we start the next public
hearing so good
job question yes are you going to be
advocating
so I I will I'm deliberating with how I
will phrase my U my Minority Report I'm
asking this for the sake of the form I
don't think you have to answer but it
would be nice if you did actually
representative Schmidt you could your
choices are to recommend ought to pass
without the amendment or itl because
retain is not an acceptable motion on
the
floor okay well that would have been my
preference but I appre appreciate the
clar ification in that case I will
recommend
itl all right thank you very much thank
you all for your thoughtful commentary
bill all right it being 10:45 I'm
opening the public hearing on
Senate Bill
15 and we will call on the prime sponsor
Senator Carson as soon as we can get her
over
here Madam Sher she is listed in the
attendees list yes we're working
changing her over okay thank you she's
in very good Senator Carson you can
uh okay good morning Madam chair and
good morning um to the house executive
departments and administration committee
it's good to see uh all of your faces
after um the covid year that we've had
so I'm going to begin by um first of all
thanking you for the work that you've
done on the house bills we started
hearing uh the house bills last week and
uh some of them are on the Senate
calendar this week and we just had a a
fabulous hearing on the a proposal by a
group of children from Hollis on the New
Hampshire jumping spider so uh thank you
again for all your hard
work um Madam chair um this morning I am
presenting to you Senate Bill 15 which
is relative to the r ra ification of
amendments to the State Building Code um
this bill ratifies certain amendments to
the state building code and the state
fire
code Madam chair um this bill um has
been around for at least a year um as
you know uh they can't the uh the board
cannot ratify amendments without getting
legislative approval and there was a
bill last year that passed uh house Edna
and it came to the Senate and
and we uh we ceased operations and so
what ended up happening it got put into
one of the Omnibus bills which was House
Bill
1234 which we know was vetoed by the
governor so uh this year I filed um
Senate Bill 15 we do know that they need
to get these amendments adopted they're
long overdue and again that's why uh you
have this bill today so at this point I
will uh
uh stop talking and uh be more than
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you Senator are there questions
representative laus uh thank you mad
chair I don't know if this is best uh
answered by the senator by you and my
question is how do these changes relate
to the bill that we heard earlier that
seemed to be on a similar topic Senate
Bill 15 is identical to House Bill 72 as
submitted it does not include the
amendment that that we passed to House
Bill 72 and if this were to go forward
we would have to incorporate that plus
other additions that I believe Marshall
questions thank you very much Senator
good morning good morning Madam chair
and members of the committee my name is
Paul paresi and it is my privilege to
serve as the State Fire Marshall and uh
I am here this morning in support of
Senate Bill 15 the ratification of the
Amendments for the state and building uh
State Fire and and building codes um as
Senator Carson pointed out this was
brought forward last year in in House
Bill
1234 um unfortunately that that was
vetoed by the governor um but it it was
you know I think it held support both in
the in the house and the Senate with
relative to um how the uh the both the
chambers looked at this the um the the
Amendments that the board of Fire
Control do um or pass um expire after 12
months if they're not ratified by the
general court so what the board of Fire
Control did this past de December was
they
ratified the Amendments that they had
previously uh adopted so that they would
be fresh and still in play for you to uh
ratify uh this legislative session so um
as representative McGuire pointed out we
would suggest a an amendment which
essentially uh mirrors the amendment
that um you folks uh did to House Bill
72 which would Encompass the four
exhibits that the board of Fire Control
uh took under consideration and uh
passed um this past December and was uh
approved by the commissioner of safety
in January and those are exhibits
20-45 uh
20055 20615 and
20715 and then as uh representative
Maguire also pointed out I believe that
um there has been interest in on the
building code side to adopt uh what I
believe is called appendix Q which uh
deals with tiny houses because the
building code uh nor the building code
nor the fire code really address tiny
houses right now so that's all I have uh
Madam chair I'd be certainly happy to
answer any questions yes representative
Schmidt has a
question thank you madam chair and good
morning Marshall uh I didn't quite get
my hand up quickly enough to ask the
question of Senator Carson and I believe
she has left the meeting at the
at this point uh but are you aware
whether the Senate is uh on board with
the changes that you just referenced uh
that we made to our bill uh which
improved it in my opinion um and the
question is whether uh it's the Senate
has any knowledge of it um and has taken
any position on it uh even
subsequently thank you for the question
uh representative Schmidt I don't
believe they've taken it up yet so I I
shouldn't offer an opinion okay
representative Schmidt I can help you
with that thank you 72 has not yet
passed the house with the amendment I
have SP I have spoken
to Senator Carson and Senator Reagan and
others who are been involved in building
code issues in the past they support the
amendment they also support the
additional amendment to add section Quee
on Tiny Houses I don't know how
widespread that support is but at least
some people have expressed support well
thank you very much because I think
that's very important that we that we
wind up with a successful bill this time
uh hoping that the governor will not
veto this one uh and um so thank you for
your efforts already on this and let's
stay stay
tuned okay represent lus uh yes for the
fire Marsh I saw the exhibits that were
sent although I haven't yet looked at
them in detail is the uh the changes
requested related to tiny houses one of
that uh thank you for the question uh
representative they are not um we that
was something that's coming up under the
uh the building code review board and an
amendment that they would they would uh
be
proposing yes um could we get a copy of
that sent to the committee I'd like to
see it before we exact
this I believe that the building CO
review board can provide it I'll ask
you right representative
Sher thank you this is a question of the
chair um since we don't actually have a
proposal yet regarding the tiny houses
is it the plan of the chair to hold this
bill until such time as we may have
that uh I think that's one thing we
could
do Senator Carson and I agreed that one
of the bills will be amended to contain
all of the pieces and sent to the
governor and the other one will be
retained in committee whether our
committee or
hers to pick up any further changes this
year and uh or in case of emergency
but but we definitely want to get one
bill and send it to the governor without
it being in an Omnibus containing
elements that that could be
needed right understandable so so you'll
just be working with Senator Carson to
see uh which Bill suits the timing the
best
yes any other questions for Marshall
paresi
all right thank you thank you madam
poock good morning can you hear me yep
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee I'm aric I'm an attorney at
Gallagher Callahan and gartell in
conquered New Hampshire I'm also a
registered lobbyist for the New
Hampshire homebuilders Association I
really just wanted to join uh and supply
for your record the support of the Home
Builders Association as a stakeholder in
discussions relating to building and
fire code amendments as they've been
processed through the building code
review board and the State's Fire
Control Board and I agree with the
procedural history provided by Senator
Carson and uh Fire Marshall perzy that
this subject matter was well pawed
through in the past and it uh
unfortunately uh was a victim of an
Omnibus Gathering of other subject
matter um we would also support uh the
amendment to the uh to the more recent
exhibit amendments to the fire code as
the Fire Marshall had referenced and
also the an amendment to add reference
to appendix Q uh of the uh International
residential code uh those are all
matters that our association have
supported and just by way of explanation
exhibit Q or appendix Q is uh a document
that relates to newer versions of the
code than is what is now in place and
adopted in New Hampshire and it would
fill a void for the 2015 code to bring
that appendix forward and make it part
of our operating code here in the state
and so that's why uh that subject matter
is coming forward as a separate matter
and as an amendment so we would support
all of the above and appreciate your
your time
Paul representative
Schmid thank you madam chair uh attorney
poock uh just to double confirm uh so
you're totally supportive of the uh the
Amendments that the house is either that
sorry that this committee has already
adopted or uh recommended and uh and and
in all it all the forms that we've
discussed this morning that's correct
representative we support uh the
committee recommendation of ought to
pass on House Bill 72 as amended and uh
Senate Bill 15 with the Amendments we've
discussed this morning okay just that
thank you for that clarification thank
you you're
welcome any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much Mr poock my
pleasure is there anyone else who wishes
O'Brien thank you madam chair I do have
one additional question with your
allowance may I ask uh Fire Marshall
perzy please you still here
yes uh Fire Marshall thank you for
taking the question I'm Believe It or
Not unfamiliar with appendix q that was
mentioned by attorney poock uh you're
okay with that if that does come in with
this particular Bill and can you just
you know give us your opinion out that
please thank you for the question
representative O'Brien good to see you
this morning yes we are good with that
um currently you know I think we need to
have some some gu rails on what we're
going to do with tiny houses and this
this would do that for both the code
official as well as the Builder so it's
it's it's a good it's good addition to
questions is there anyone else who
hearing unless somebody has prepared an
amendment I haven't seen I don't think
exe and we have 15 minutes until our
next uh next hearing so let's take a
short break oh oh
okay no we can't do 141 until after we
have the hearing on the
amendment reference to that that's okay
well Madam chair I just want to say uh
this is an example of the kind of
serious and uh fruitful work that this
committee can uh produce and especially
your efforts in staying on top of the
differences between what we've already
adopted in this committee and but hasn't
gone through the house yet and what the
Senate is bringing us uh this is uh very
important and you see the support of not
only attorney Pollock but the fire
marshal and so your your efforts in
maintaining contact with the uh senate
committee are very much appreciated by
all of us I'm
representative Madame chair would you
like me to pursue an amendment for um
the room has been muted representative
gr so she can't I mean she can talk
standing I'm assuming they couldn't hear
me I'll ask question when we come back
sure
for
hanging
around all right welcome back to
housea I'm opening the hearing house
Carson there we go good morning Madam
chair again um for the record um my name
is Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure
of representing Senate District 14
comprising The Town of London da Hudson
and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
106 which deals with um adopting Omnibus
legislation related to codes um there
are two parts of this bill the first is
repealing the voluntary fire service
equipment certification and the second
is establishing a committee to study
adopting changes to the State Fire and
Building Codes um Madam chair how would
you like me to proceed would you like me
to just uh talk about the first part of
the bill and and uh and then allow T
other testimony and then continue on to
part two or would you like me to do them
both at the same time I think for
purposes of our understanding we rather
do it section by
section position to you but on the
bigger omnibuses but it will help us a
great deal not a problem Madam chair
Okay so so the first bill the first uh
the first one's fairly easy um the
repealing the voluntary fire service
equipment certification this bill uh was
filed at the request of the State Fire
Marshal's office and I believe um the
Fire Marshall is here to uh discuss with
you why he wanted this uh legislation
filed and with that with that I will
conclude my testimony and go back into
the waiting room all right thank you
thank you Marshall
pory good morning once again Madame
chair members of the committee again my
name is Paul paresi and I am still the
State Fire Marshal and uh I am here in
support of uh house correction Senate
Bill 106 part one which repeals the
voluntary fire service equipment
certification program this program uh
was established under Senate Bill 355
back in 2004 and went into effect on
January 1st of
2005 uh the program was initially uh
established to encourage service
technicians who are installing and
servicing Fire Equipment such as fire
alarm systems sprinkler systems and so
forth to be certified in New Hampshire
and in order to be certified they would
have to prove proficiency through an
outside credentialing agency such as the
National Institute of certification and
engineering technology or net uh the
International Code Council which is ICC
uh they would had to have uh been a
current professional engineer or
something similar and it would it was
envisioned that someday this program
would become uh mandatory and then it
would tighten up the Fly by Night actors
in the business who are not sufficiently
trained or educated to conduct these
operations the program was originally uh
had an advisory committee uh that was
established to assist the commissioner
in rulemaking requirements uh the
committee was repealed uh under
uh House Bill 1690 in 2010 and since
then the law has remained unchanged as
had the administrative rules which were
safe C
,00 uh in 2019 we began reviewing uh the
possibility of re roping uh safy 1200
and we conducted an analysis of the
program and and uh determined that there
were fewer than 20 participants in the
program and the revenue was under $1,000
annually we contacted various
stakeholders in the trade uh as well as
fire service folks and uh we came to the
conclusion that there was little value
in keeping the uh voluntary program we
do uh think that there's value in
someday bringing it back uh as a
mandatory program if all of the
stakeholders are in agreement to do so
so with that uh we Advocate that we uh
that you repeal the program under uh RSA
1535 a and I'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you thank you very
much representative
O'Brien uh thank you madam chair um
thank you Fire Marshall for taking my
question maybe it isn't relevant but I
would appreciate your
explanation in the case that a
vendor uh in some municipalities has to
be certified by that particular fire
alarm division in order to access the
municipal own fire box place it on
manual go in and work on the system
within the timely fashion by you know
the code and everything and uh replace
the box back on from manual back on to
automatic this does nothing to alleviate
the responsibility do they still have to
notify farm that they're in Municipal
equipment that they're uh isolated that
box and made it from automatic to uh
manual so therefore the uh proper trans
mission of alarm would be generated as
what the intention of the fire alarm
panel is to
do thank you very much for the question
uh uh representative O'Brien and yes
this would have nothing to do with what
municipalities or local fire departments
require of their uh service technicians
or vendors to work specifically on fire
alarm or sprinkler systems or other
fixed Fire Protection Systems within
their community so uh NASA for instance
Salem there's uh manest there's a lot of
a lot of departments have what's called
a certificate of fitness program which
is uh allowed under the state fire code
now those municipalities can continue to
have those programs this would just
questions representative
Shu thank you madam chair um good
morning Marshall pesi uh you mentioned
that the original provision uh was put
into um I don't know what I don't recall
the word you used oversee or investigate
Bad
actors um who were doing these kinds of
things without uh proper knowledge so
are you not seeing any evidence of
people doing that uh recently
or
thank you for the question
representative I I think that there will
always be folks out there that are doing
things that they shouldn't be doing um
what this does is it it it leaves it to
the municipalities to really enforce
that so um a local fire department for
instance if they don't have a
certificate of fitness program uh which
we encourage them to do but if they
don't have one then they would need to
work with their uh local uh law
enforcement agency to uh bring forward
uh some sort of charge uh to to someone
who's doing something that they
shouldn't be to a fire alarm system uh
under the state fire code which they can
they can certainly do but as far as um
we don't we haven't had a when we
contacted the fire chiefs regarding this
issue we didn't hear them uh say that
this was going to be a detriment and
they wouldn't you know that there were
so many uh folks out there not doing a
good good job that it was going to be a
problem and it was voluntary anyway
really the only thing that would have
teeth is if it was a mandatory program
side thank you representative fellows
thank you madam chair um my question has
to do with the small towns the ones that
don't even have that don't have maybe
full-time um fire departments and if
this would perhaps negatively impact the
safety in those
communities I'm wondering who who is
doing the work on these um fire alarm
systems
and if the small really small fire
departments are not going to I'm I'm
just thinking that somebody works on on
a fire alarm panel the people who are in
that building think that it works fine
and maybe it doesn't because the people
who worked on it don't know what they
were doing so who who is doing this work
and to what extent are people not
qualified to do
it thank you for the question
representative and it's certainly a fair
question um so um right now even with
this law in place nothing is nothing
prevents anybody from just going in and
conducting that kind of uh work let's
say on a on a sprinkler system or a fire
system um and that's it's unfortunate
but that's that's just the way it is uh
currently um so it would be up to um a
local Fire official to make sure that uh
the work is being done um you know in in
in a correct manner um but this this
particular law because there's only 20
or there's fewer than 20 folks that are
registered in this voluntary program it
really wasn't doing anything anyway the
only folks that were registering were
the folks that were on the up and up so
um
although so I guess it this this the
elimination of this program really
doesn't do anything um to either help or
hurt the situation that that you
describe and to to Really eliminate the
problem that you describe we would need
to make this a mandatory program and
then have an enforcement mechanism uh
tied to it so so what kind of people are
doing this
work uh well it depends on what kind of
what kind of uh fixed um protection
system we're talking about sprinkler
work is typically done by a sprinkler
contractor sometimes a plumber but
typically a sprinkler contractor or a
mechanical outfit firearm uh work is
done either by electricians who who if
they're an electrician typically they're
licensed but there are um folks that
just do uh low voltage stuff such as uh
burglar alarm and fire alarm systems and
licensed thank you you're welcome
representative leas thank you madam
chair so just to get a a feel for the
impact or lack thereof of this uh you
said there's fewer than 20 that are
licensed do you have a general feel as
to how many people in the state are
doing this kind of work I mean is this a
tiny fraction the less than 20 a tiny
thing thank you representative for the
question yeah that there's there are
hundreds of uh contractors out there
doing this kind of work and so this is a
very small fraction of those that are
out there doing the work thank you
repres
sh thank you madam chair
um Marshall py you raised a question in
my mind uh why are you not asking
instead this change to become
mandatory thank you for the question
representative it's a it's a great
question and I think that someday we
will bring this back as a mandatory
program we're just not prepared to do it
at this time and because the
administrative rules expired the really
the correct way to do this is to take
the law off the books for now and then
if we want to bring it back if we can if
we can agree as with the with all of the
stakeholders to bring it back um in a
robust way uh then I think we will um
clearly the the folks that are committed
to uh fire protection and the folks that
are doing it the right way are going to
be on board with this it'll be the it'll
be the fly by nights that won't be so um
we suspect that we will bring it back at
some point but there they will you know
there's with that comes uh you know
certification or licensing fees and all
that sort of stuff and um you know we
just weren't prepared to bring that
thank you representative
fellows um thank you madam chair so just
to follow up to represent on
representative shu's question
um if you have 20 or so people right now
who have this voluntary
certification and in the next year or
two we were to try to put together a
program where people are certified with
fees I'm wondering if it might be better
to just let these
people um have their keep their not if
it's might be better to not eliminate
this program so that those people who do
have this
certification can be grandfathered and
not have to um maybe take a test again
or pay a higher
fee thank you representative the the the
vast majority of the fewer than 20 that
had the certif certification in the last
couple of years most of those have
expired anyway and then they would be
required to take a test to recertify
anyway so even under the voluntary
program it's not just something that
they automatically renew they have to
questions okay seeing none thank you
Marshall py and
let's
[Music]
see uh Mr poock I believe you're you're
two correct Madam chair uh the Home
Builders Association has no position
relative to part one okay does anyone
else wish to testify on part one of
106 all right seeing none we'll move on
Carson thank you thank you again um
Madame chair um I will introduce the
second part of the bill which is
establishing a committee to study
adopting changes to the State Fire and
Building Codes again this was a request
of the State Fire Marshall and I just
like to uh state that in November of
uh the house bill 1254 which Madam chair
I believe you were a part of which was
the committee to study the procedures
for adoption of national codes by the
state of New Hampshire recommended a
standard procedure and timeline for the
adoption of codes the recommendation was
that New Hampshire should adopt model
codes one cycle
behind um we should have adopted the
2018 codes in 2020 but I think um
because of covid that did not happen um
and so at this point Madam chair I'm
going to turn it over to uh again our
State Fire Marshall to give you an
explanation and I thank you for your
time and thank the committee as well
thank you Senator so
py thank you madam chair for the record
my name is Paul pesy and I serve as the
State Fire Marshall it's my privilege to
do so and as Senator Caron uh indicated
uh House Bill 1254 uh did indicate that
we should try to the best that we can
adopt uh codes one cycle behind so this
would be the year that we would be
looking at adopting the 2018 code here
in 201 uh
um we did you probably remember uh we
did a what we call a double jump in 2015
when we adopted uh correction in 201 18
when we we adopted the 15 codes because
we came from the
2009 and then we we skipped over the
2012 code and went right to the 2015
code and to do that double jump was a
pretty heavy lift to uh not only from
our side to try to put all the pieces
together as far as what all the changes
were but also from the contractor's side
to have to play that kind of catchup uh
and certainly there was uh you know
there was some
in making that happen but we were able
to do it and it was great but I think
what 1254 highlighted to us was we
really need to try to stay more current
with the codes and rather than fall 10
years behind like we did last time we
want to try to be you know more in the
in the three or so year range um so um
we had originally proposed this bill as
let's adopt the 2018 code set um and to
do that the border of control in the
building codee review board typically um
dissect both uh both of their codes and
they come forward with some
recommendations for um amendments to
those codes because there are some part
parts of the mo model code that may not
work in New Hampshire so uh as we've
seen before and we have a a whole list
of amendments to our uh model codes um
so this year the board of Fire Control
got out a little bit ahead of the
building code review board so the board
of Fire Control uh got got the fire code
flushed out and they were ready to go
for adoption this year uh the building
code review board primarily due to covid
uh just was unable to put it you know
get the final uh report done so they're
not quite ready uh to move forward with
the adoption just yet so um and and you
know we could you know suggest that we
that that we split the baby so to speak
and say adopt the fire code and we'll
we'll do the we'll catch up with the
building code later but I think that
really the the wise thing to do is keep
them together as much as we possibly can
and adopt the fire and building codes
together so uh with that we're
supporting uh this change to uh uh a
study committee for uh the building of
fire codes with the um with the strong
hope and Will that this adop gets that
they both get adopted uh in the next
legislative season so thank you very
much for the opportunity to testify and
i' be happy to answer any questions
thank you I have a question uh I was on
the previous uh study committee on code
process so is it your intention that
this committee would work with the
building code review board and the Fire
Control Board to develop legislation
for next year in 2022 to to go to the
2018 code with the appropriate
amendments
thank you for the question Madam chair
yes I I think that that would exactly be
what we'd like to see happen thank you
very much representative Roy has a
question thank you madam chair thank you
Marshall crazy um if if we were to
separate them out um that would cause
problems because there are overlapping
fire codes that have implications on
regular building code is that correct
thank you representative Roy that's that
that's correct cor we we we'll end up
with a conflict there'll be multiple
conflicts we've done it before and it
you know we we got through it but it it
does create conflict thank you okay
other
questions I think
that I don't see any other
questions thank you very much thank you
madam
chair Mr
Pollock good morning again for your
record Maric of Gallagher Callahan and
Garrell here is a lobbyist for the New
Hampshire Home Builders uh again I'm
adding my voice to the chorus of support
for uh for this bill uh code related I
agree with the procedural history
provided by Senator Carson and Fire
Marshall perzy and I also agree uh it
didn't take us very long to ride off the
rails of former House Bill 1254 but such
as life in a pandemic uh and uh there
are uh some uh
inconsistencies between the 2018
building codes and the 2018 fire codes
that uh in a more normal setting uh
would have been able to be worked out
behind the scenes but that work remains
in progress today uh and in fact there
is a joint committee on codes uh that
has had several meetings already uh to
do that work and it's my hope uh as a
stakeholder uh or representing a
stakeholder in the conversation that the
legislative committee that's uh formed
uh by this bill can preside over those
discussions and uh exactly as was asked
earlier fashion a bill for next year so
that those codes can move forward
there's there's no intent to delay
there's no intent to Sidetrack it's just
that work needs to be done on those
inconsistencies uh as representative Roy
mentioned because it's very difficult to
handle those inconsistencies in the
field when you have officials with
concurrent
jurisdiction um happy to take any
questions but we are in support of part
two of uh Senate Bill 106 thank you
excellent thank you representative lus
uh thank you chair um you mentioned um a
joint committee on codes and what what
is that made up of and what would that
committee's relationship be with the
proposed
one so I believe it is a statutory
committee uh comprised of officials from
the building uh officials uh and and the
fire officials uh stakeholders such as
the homebuilders association often
attend those meetings and listen to the
content uh but I believe it is primarily
a forum to iron out these
inconsistencies and to try and have
their respective uh other statutory
boards such as the building code review
board Andor the Fire Control Board make
amendments to the model codes so that
they not only conform to New Hampshire's
practices and specific needs uh but also
iron out those
inconsistencies follow up followup so
how would you see um you know that
committee interacting with the proposed
uh new one how's this all going to work
the new one would be comprised of
legislators who would be educated on the
issue so that a bill could come forward
and the uh inconsistencies be explained
as part of the legislative process that
the other joint committee uh is uh admin
ministrative they're they're not uh
staffed by
legislators thank
questions okay I don't see any thank you
Mr paa is there anyone else who wishes
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on Senate Bill
106 the committee will resume at 1:15
[Music]
good afternoon welcome
back and I'm opening the public hearing
on Senate Bill 42 and I call Senator
R good afternoon members of house
executive departments and
administration it's uh I'm pleased to
bring to you today Senate Bill
42 and Senate Bill
42 um corrects an admission
to um what is already an
RSA and
it adds
to the RSA that
public officials are barred
from um Contracting or buying or selling
anything in excess of $200 without an
bid thank
[Music]
you are there any quot questions from
the
committee ah
yes representative Schmidt of course is
in thank you madam chair welcome back to
house Edna
Senator I remember well those days when
you served with us for four years um and
you've gone on to bigger and better
things uh
anyway my question for you sir is uh are
we currently
experiencing U abuse of this situation
or is this more of a hypothetical which
nevertheless needs to be
addressed no it's actually
town yeah thank you pres
Pearson thank you madam chair um just at
this just for some clarity and and
apologize ahead of time here so when it
talks about buying real
estate that that would not put you in a
situation where you
would you would just buy real estate
that was listed in an MLs or anything
correct yeah that seems to be
correct follow up Madam chair
yes the other the other Clarity I'm just
looking for here is when you talk about
providing
services in excess of
$200 and it says a political subdivision
under which he he or she holds public
office so as a state representative that
would mean I couldn't offer services to
the town of dairy unless I'm from I
represent Dairy I couldn't offer um
services to the town of dairy unless
those were in a competitive bidding but
I could let's say for the town of
Raymond
yes you have no control of what the town
of Raymond does right but it means the
selectman in Dairy would not be able to
auditor okay how would that affect a
county official would that that would
apply countywide as
sir
but the C that would only affect County
officials so we elect a county
commissioner they can't provide like I
said the audit services to the to the
county they can't act
so this simply
expands the
current ban on selling Goods or
Commodities to providing Services which
are much more prevalent than they used
to
be
okay
all right representative
Judy yes thank you Madame chair uh
Senator again nice to see you um I Heard
Madame chair uh Senator $200 but uh I
please
Senor you repeat I'm not understanding
your question if I may the the question
was the $200 is for
what any
service any service all right so thank
you very
much black um thank you madam chair I
mean I think a practical example that
might help with that is uh you know the
board of Selectmen could not hire one of
the selectman to do plowing for the town
for example as a service something like
questions thank you well they could
provide the service if they were if they
participated in a bidd bidding process
okay
thank you madam chair um it occurs to me
that for example uh representative
Pearson uh who is a
firefighter if he wanted to say work
part-time as an EMT in his town um I
don't know for sure what Derry has but
in my town we just have a call fire
department or volunteer fire department
that gets paid by call
uh would he be in violation of this if
he did that say on a part-time basis
that would be a contractual obligation
on his
part he's Contracting with the town to
perform that
service right so would that be in
violation of this no thank
you representative
fellows thank you madam chair um Senator
Reagan I'm wondering if um in the when
you heard this in the Senate if there
was any discussion or if you have any
suggestions about either raising that
$200 to a higher level or the other
issue was it's it it sounds like if you
were talking about snow plowing that if
they were doing it on a Pur storm basis
that you know it could be like $190 each
time and they might do it 10 times in a
winter was there any discussion of
that no if your word of selectman is
that devious I don't know what you do to
stop
that thank you representative
sh um thank you for taking my question
um I was just trying to find the answer
on my own um but I have not found the
answer so maybe you can help me I see
that this is in the section uh regarding
ing the general court would this need to
be disclosed if someone did
receive um a contract or sell a property
and all the things that you've outlined
would would it need to be a part of the
disclosure statement process or in what
uh way is that
disclosed I believe there's a threshold
for
that to what do you if you don't mind
when asking what do you mean by that you
mean the Dollar's threshold amount that
we
disclose and it would automatically be
in that our financial reportings anyway
is what I think you're saying it might
be yeah thank
you president laus uh thank you madam
chair um there was aate a statement that
um you know for the somebody was uh
acting as an EMT um maybe on a contract
basis I think that would that might
still be included I'm not sure because
it says contract or otherwise except by
open competitive bidding I don't know
you know if it's a there's a standard
amount they're going to pay you know per
hour let's say um whether there' be any
problem with um you know let's say
represented Pearson doing that kind of
work in Dair it's not clear to me
not I could representative Roy has an
answer I think if you're talking about
the
firefighting duties if you were to
volunteer or work par time I think by
its nature um it's a it's a It's Kind
like
contractual and putting out to bid to
fill
positions um you see what I mean with
things um it says by contract or
otherwise want which seems pretty
inclusive I mean I I support this in
general I'm just wondering what the
implications might be kind
situation thank you Senator reikan do
you have any wisdom for
us I I would it's I would think it'd be
people not being available to compete
for
employment and that would be a decision
was representative font
now thank you madam chair I guess uh I
think my question went back to the same
as representative luckus regarding that
that Clause that says by contract or
otherwise then it says except by open
competitive bidding and I'm wondering if
there's an explanation or a definition
for exactly what that means by open
competitive bidding does that mean that
that the position or the has been
advertised at a
certain in a certain medium or you know
is there some written constraints to
that open competitive bidding Clause I
now representative at lro do you have
some wisdom for us on that yeah I I I
don't have the certainty answer to that
but I know that uh virtually every state
agency and
institution has um a definition for what
open competitive bidding is so I think
Reagan thank you thank you for showing
up Senator and for humoring us with
these
questions good to be
here is there anyone else who wishes to
42 I don't see any hands so I'm closing
the public
[Music]
hearing okay representative Roy has
moved off to pass on Senate Bill 42
is there a second I'll
second representative La of sections do
you wish to speak to your motion um yeah
just briefly um I I had introduced last
last term similar legislation regarding
except the off with um public employees
accepting things from private businesses
um I think that anytime that we have an
opportunity to to prevent
even the appearance of impropriety in
public offices we should we should jump
at that I think the concern about
employment is is a little a little bit
of a stretch because when you hire
people you automatically you put it out
there for positions and there's laws
that cover discrimination or or already
that cover nepotism things like this so
I feel like you know unless it's a a
position that was created just for that
Public Employee and no one else could
apply for it you wouldn't run into a
problem with this and if that was the
case you would want to run into this
problem so I I just don't see that as a
big impediment and like I said it's more
important to um to alleviate the
appearance of impropriety in public
office you wish to speak to your second
yeah just briefly uh it's uh this is an
issue of um oh gosh you just drove it in
my head because you said it you said
basically what I want going to say but
in in the couple of rare cases where
there may be employment issues the the
bottom line is just going back to the
one concern that people seem to have was
that all of these positions are going to
be covered by equal employment
opportunity regulations and so um
avoiding um conflict of interest is the
word I'm looking for even if in a couple
of rare cases where things are on the
borderline between contract and um
employment um
there's always the next town over and
it's better to avoid the uh the conflict
of interest issue as uh representative
Roy said Thank you represent
schills thank you um I find this really
interesting and overall do like the bill
I think it would be I would be more
supportive of it if um we could amend it
to either somehow make thec disclosure
of being a one of the categories of
elected officials that are in the bill
or some other measure to maybe amend our
financial disclosure or possibly um file
some sort of an Ethics form um to say
that someone has um participated in that
open bid process over a certain amount
of money maybe even $200 is um too low
or you know too that is too low of
amount for the
disclosure maybe but um I think though
this sort of um ethics reform is is a
great start to possibly a handful of
Ethics reforms we could potentially
discuss and I really like uh the concept
and hope we can maybe find some common
ground on more of this at some point in
the future all right represent s
this is just an expansion of existing
policy right there no yes this merely
the representative Alro yeah again I
think um this will be covered under all
public records rules in almost every
imaginable case anyway that's a good
point uh that uh um Representative makes
but again just like the E eeo laws are
already in place I I'm guessing this
would all be a matter of public record
anyway so the disclosure is automatic I
may be incorrect in that but that's what
I would
expect represent uh thank you I think if
the concern is our disclosure if I
recall correctly we only have to
disclose sources of income of $10,000 or
more and
so um you know if if we're getting paid
more than that let's say you had a
contract you know with the town to do
something and it was competitive B it
was fine if you got more than $10,000
for maybe you're you've got a Paving
Company and you're doing Paving for the
town um you know if it's above that
limit you'd have to disclose it as a
representative my guess is this is uh
more aimed at Boards of Selectmen or
maybe even School boards or whatever
with the person sits on the board
directly making the decision on how to
spend the money um my guess is that's a
bigger concern as as I read it
representative La it doesn't would not
affect us
making uh providing services to our
towns because we're not elected to the
task we are elected to the state so that
we couldn't uh get a sweetheart
HS representative
fellows thank you madam chair um
I'm I I support the concept of what's
going on here and I definitely agree
that this statute should in include
services and I'm thinking of it um from
the perspective of of a um select
board and when they need might want
services and I'm so when
you let me start again so one aspect
about this bill before it was amended is
it only dealt with things that would be
individual transactions because they're
talking about selling real estate buying
goods buying um property in Commodities
when you put in the services you run
into a situation where it could be
services that are provided
weekly and um then then I start to
wonder about that 200
$200 and if you're going to do something
and you get $150 for it but it's weekly
then then it's exempt but it's a lot for
the um the the entire year so I don't
know if that should be changed to $200
per fiscal year the other thing that
that just
seems like it's an an issue is the fact
that um the limits at which you need to
put things out to bid I'm assuming that
those are not set by Statute and they're
probably set by the um in in towns
they're probably set by the selectman or
by the city Alderman so if we put in a
fixed
amount I mean that can come in con
conflict with them I mean I I I don't
want to see somebody there nobody's
going to want to put out a bid for
something that cost $300 possibly so
that's that's a concern also and I like
the concept I just think it's could
cause problems and I'm disappointed that
Municipal Services is not here to maybe
issues repr
Roy um I just wanted to to well actually
I'll comment on a couple things with the
with the question about the cumulative
effect um if if you are the person who
plows for the town and you get $150 a
pop I would argue that that does fall
within that because it's it's if they
didn't put it out the bid and it's your
job to do it all winter long you've gone
over that because it's you're the person
who plows it's if you follow what I'm
saying that's even if it's not a written
contract you're the one who's expected
to show up and plow every stor then you
are getting more than $200 because
you're doing it over the whole winter I
think you'd be hard pressed to make an
argument that that no I'm only doing it
because if they don't put every storm
out the bid and you're the one who gets
it that you're by clearly uh the person
who's um who's the only one to do it so
yeah I think I think that's that answers
thank you madam chair and I too had
the same concerns uh as representative
fellows because of the wording at any
one sale to or from um and that concerns
me because it could be anyone who does
uh multiple service contracts um with
the city or town could be someone who
owns for instance a um who's a mechanic
and repairs Vehicles as a see fit or
need to come in
um and my question would be to this
whole statute and I'm not sure when it
was implemented but is $200 too low of a
threshold should it be bumped up
um do these cities and towns need to put
a competitive bid out for every thing
that goes over $200 or should to be more
of a an upper threshold um so those are
my concerns um I'm not sure whether we
need to look into this a little further
than passing it right today it's not uh
something that's do well right
away um so I would like to see it
researched this statute was originally
passed in
1941 it was amended in 69 and then in
1975 to raise it from $25 to
$200
so
um it also deleted members of an
exception for members of the general
court in that was5 so I yes this is a
very old statute and it's not actually
been amended very many times or
something that old so we're looking the
last time the dollar averages moved up
was 197 9 74
75 so that's dollar value in 75 versus
today that's my question I think this is
a low threshold that it could be moved
thank
you all right representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well
representative goalie is already
exploring the uh area that I'm
interested in uh so what is our deadline
here because I think just one or two
questions to uh to people who are even
more knowledgeable than we are have
already been hearing from our own
committee members uh might be helpful if
we've got a couple weeks to kick this
around and make sure that we get the
dollar amount right and because
otherwise I think that adding services
in is just common
sense we may be overthinking it a bit
but uh we do not have any deadline that
I any near-term deadline on this bill
it's a Senate
bill it's probably sometime in
May I mean you know a lot of these
people in these little towns they donate
their services to the town they do X Y
and Z they don't even charge
because part part goes with the
territory but uh but to the degree that
somebody's doing something on a regular
basis uh providing a service I think
it's a appropriate to amend the statute
but we I think we have a couple of
questions we could we could F out to uh
people who do this on a daily
basis representative
Shu thank you madam chair I will just
add my voice uh to say that I I don't
see the um need to rush to judgment on
this I think we need to look into it a
more
okay represent leus uh thank you m I'm
okay either is it the way it is or or
fixing some of the the things people
think are problems but just uh for
information $200 in 1975 today is
approximately $1,000 it's about five
times since that it's a fairly low
threshold
yeah so somebody wanted to amend it up a
th
equivalent representative Roy um I'm
happy to withdraw my motion if we want
to amend the money thing my only my only
concern is the object of the bill is to
actually net as many people as we can
that are public officials that are
profiting from public money so by
raising the bar we're gonna we're gonna
we're g to affect less people that are
getting money from the public cers not
more and the object of the bill I think
is to make sure that anyone who's
profiting or may appear to be profiting
by their position in public government
is um is is disclosed there's no law in
New Hampshire that requires uh
competitive bidding based on any kind of
amount unless it's a public official so
raising that up to
$1,000 is and especially as it that we'd
have to amend the per occurrence thing
too I think because now you know that's
a significant amount amount of money
over extended period of
time I don't know I just feel like
leaving it a low threshold accomplishes
the purpose of the bill better than
giving them more
wi but that's just my opinion I'm happy
to
Def and then representative go
representative made the point
they'll be going to did a $300 contract
or or anything and I I like the idea uh
representative sh said we need to do
some research I think this is really a
feel for it I don't know that research
,000 per year uh captures representative
fellows concerned and if that's the
amendment that would be F speaking for
me that'd be fine to have ,000 over the
year that's
that okay representative
Brian uh thank you madam chair I would
uh agree with uh both uh representative
goalie and Lakers I too went to Google
and the uh inflation calculator and then
come did come up with the $1,000 and if
we look back when this bill was
originally introduced uh the intention
was the value of $200 so basically in
the maintenance because of inflation as
time goes on everything's much more uh
expensive the Thousand does make sense
to me and keeps in line with what the
original bill was intended to do in the
beginning so it's just basically a
maintenance issue maybe there's other
bills that should be taken a look at
very similarly so thank you
representative fellows thank you madam
chair um I'm just I would like to have
some
research on what um municipalities
currently do related to this maybe they
have some of their own policies in place
that that have some kind of cap on this
and so I know I can ask my um Town
manager what they do with this situation
maybe maybe they just need to disclose
it maybe they just need to adopt a
policy on this just just throwing things
out I don't know exactly what's going on
so I can't propose a
fix Bailey thank you mad
chair to me the problem is like a
category one that Services is is
completely not in the same category with
everything else and so to fix the
services you'd have to put in per
year but you wouldn't be selling real
estate the same piece of real estate
ever again or the same personal property
ever again it it doesn't Services
doesn't belong with the other things in
this
bill interesting thank you represent
laus yeah um actually I I uh think
that's not quite true has Commodities I
mean you could have own a qu in town and
you could be selling sand for sanding
and that would be an ongoing thing
that
goie thank you m chair and I just want
to go back to my original example of say
if someone who's on the board of
selectman um owns a garage and does auto
repairs for maybe the uh Town Cruiser or
some of the vehicles uh in the town um
my question is it says provide services
if he's got to go out and buy a part
that's
$200 and he doesn't know the cost until
he gets it um looked up and then he
still has to provide what it's going to
cost for him to do the work on top of
that I would assume that the cost of the
part plus what he's providing for a
service is a service
fee um so with that being said every
time a vehicle is being repaired uh does
it have to be put on hold and send out
to competitive bid before any uh piece
of equipment can be repaired um and
that's that's my concern with this low
threshold whereas $1 thousand do I think
would be more reasonable thank
you yeah I I could be mistaken thank you
for recognizing me but I think we're
losing focus on what the purpose of this
bill is for and that's to avoid conflict
of interest so whether it's $200 or
$20,000
the town selectman shouldn't be
repairing the town's police cars it's
just a conflict of interest so I think
the $200 is almost just a nominal
throwout there it as far as I'm
concerned it could just as well be zero
thank
you I understand what representative
goalie is saying and I also understand
what representative Alro is saying and I
think that
in many situations in many towns that
are large enough there's going to be
ample people to
do work right it doesn't have to be the
border of Select when that does the
stuff but in smaller towns it may be
that way so I think I just I agree that
we should I agree with representative
fellows that we should just scope it out
on the smaller town levels to make sure
that we're just not impinging on their
that's
all okay algra thank you again uh I come
from a pretty small town Campton and
thoron is less than five minutes away if
we can't get the cruiser fixed in
Campton it's really not a problem to go
over to fil where the work belongs
anyway in my opinion thank you yeah and
I I know that in my town we have a town
report every year that lists the major
contracts and and the smaller contracts
and who got paid what for services so
you could see that the
uh Road agent made so much and
the fire chief got paid so much for
regular for his regular stuff and so
much for details so that information is
published but but if you've got the
Selectmen out
there with essentially a contract to
maintain the police cruiser that is a
cont seems like a conflict of
interest I mean if you're talking about
a contract to do all the maintenance you
know and in charge individually that
to um I would also add that with
representative Go's example I'm unaware
of any town that that handles their
repairs for their vehicles on a on a at
per vehicle basis generally they have an
agreement or a contract with one
mechanic or service provider um that
handles all of their repairs I I I
wouldn't I couldn't Envision whether the
cruise is broke let's see who we can get
to repair it they generally have someone
that they send their their work to so I
okayy thank you madam chair it well it
is an example and a hypothetical example
it could very well happen and to
representative gr uh
scenario that going from Campton to
Thornton to get something repaired could
end up costing your your town more money
to have to go out of the Town versus
taking care of it in town so that's not
as good an example either um if it's a
competitive bid and it's a lower
contract I would think you would want to
keep it in your town thank
you that fellows thank you madam chair I
I can tell you little towns they like to
support the local businesses if they can
do that um the other thing that comes to
mind is what if the let's let's deal
with the auto repair issue so what if
the if it's a business that's an LLC or
it's
Incorporated and it's owned or partly
owned by a person who's on the select
board so is that the same as paying on
on the books you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know what was going on um is
that okay if you're paying a business
select there just just seems like a lot
of
issues get deep into the weeds represent
leus thank you um as I said before I'd
be okay passing this the way it is you
know or if somebody wants to amend it
but uh you know I would I would think
that if there is a violation somebody's
going to have to you know how would it
be enforced I assume somebody would have
to bring it
up um and although I don't generally
like leaving things to the court some of
these fine details I don't think we can
think of all of them and that's the sort
of thing that the courts would end up
dealing with if there was a case
brought we can't solve everything here I
don't think I I kind of think we're the
wrong group to deal with this this
should be in Municipal and County rather
than on this committee because
this sounds like the sort of things that
we just County deals with so we're we're
kind of out of our depth uh
representative Roy if you will withdraw
your motion I think that would be the
best action to
uh sure I'll be happy to withraw okay
you transfer to County if you can uh
I'll try but I we held a hearing so we
may not be able to we can certain
go consult yeah and we should all talk
to our towns and
say because it's laws been on the book
for 80 years all right we should be your
town should have a know how they deal
with it and hi lisis Mike O'Brian how
are
you yes Mike if you would if
you yeah I booked a m for tomorrow so I
had to take that call all right glad
what's that I'm
sorry I said we're glad to hear you're
okay but I yeah we we we should each do
some research on what we can how this is
handled now because these issues should
not be
new and it's only the question of
whether it's you know whether you're
delivering a case of uh milk to the town
offices every week or or whatever for
fing the
books anything we do will be an
improvement it may not be the best
Improvement but if we don't do anything
it's worse than than not making a small
Improvement so let's let's pull some of
the weeds out here but we do have a
month or so okay to do some research
before we decide that we'll just take
the bill
fine all right so everybody research the
your issues and we'll see what happens
yes representative
fellow I would just like to say that if
if you're going to talk to your town
managers one of the things might to ask
be to ask them if they have a policy
about this not just the issue of the uh
dollar limit because they may be
handling it some other way in terms of
disclosure
maybe they should be handling it some
way we don't know exactly how all right
well that was
that and we hardly looked at the issue
at
all no I wouldn't say that I'm I'm I'm
joking I'm joking it would make a great
topic for what I did with my
summer EXC Madam chairman would you like
me to contact the municipal Association
and see if they have some insight on the
these questions yes please that would be
delightful okay great and anything else
let me know what I can do I think they
they should have general information on
how this is covered right right now and
they may know if there's issues with it
okay but we talk to our town managers
for select them absolutely something
something we should we do
anyway
okay we have a few minutes until 2:00
when we're hearing our Second non-
141 did you wish to make a motion
you I I couldn't hear what that was he
hasn't made the motion yet he's agreeing
that he will
make
wasn't actually planning on doing motion
this okay sorry if you're not letting on
want actually sorry
um I was thinking about the other Bill
the other build I if it's okay I'll make
it not to pass motion on HD 106 orb 106
so on Senate Bill 106 representative
pass like to speak to your
motion yes I mean there's two parts to
this um repealing the voluntary fire
service equipment certification seems
like something we should do since it's
accomplishing basically nothing um
there's only a tiny fraction of the
people uh installing the equipment who
get it and so it's providing no benefit
at this
time and
um part two as I understand it there are
boards that that review the um fire code
of the building code but having a a
committee of legislators
involved and presumably following that
uh process and then you know creating
and or reviewing any legisl should
Implement I think is a good idea because
it's not a simple
topic
yes I'd like to add on regard that
committee the last time we updated the
building codes it came through
Edna
and even with the support of the
building code review board and the fire
marshal and some members of the
committee who were very knowledgeable
about codes it took us a great deal of
effort to resolve some of the the
conflicts that uh the political
conflicts in the building code less so
in the fire code fortunately and then
the conflicts between the fire code and
the building code and having a
smaller probably somewhat more
knowledgeable group would be very would
be helpful and regarding the inv
voluntary fire service equipment if
essentially the Fire Marshall is saying
the program at this point is not worth
going through rule writing and their
current rules have expired they don't
want it it's just not worth the effort
and the the stakeholders do not seem to
care about the
process so nobody wants it let's let's
get rid of it if we need to deal with it
later we
will representative
Shu thank you madam chair um at the risk
of sounding like someone who has her
feet mired in
mud um I was hoping that we could wait
on this a little bit uh I had attempted
to reach out over the weekend to the
fire chief in my town and have been able
unable to make contact with him uh
particularly concern as to the voluntary
fire service equipment I just wanted to
have a conversation with him and have
been unable to do that as yet so was
hoping I could put off making a decision
on that part of this bill I'm certainly
in favor of the other
section repr
BR thank you madam chair I so if we um
I'm just thinking of the of the timeing
I'm fine with the bill but I'm trying to
um the committee BAS basically would be
in would be in charge of monit of
assessing what would need to get done in
adopting the F the state fire codes and
the state building
codes because of potential points of
conflict between the two
correct yes okay also go ahead I'm sorry
so amendments that are political in
nature to some degree okay
now they
would so they would have until
November of this year to
incorporate to put this together for the
correct and then we would put into
legislation adopting the 2018 fire codes
year correct yes so
then we would do this subsequently with
every adoption of the upcoming fire code
is that
correct uh we would do something either
this separate committee or we could have
had a bill in this year that to to study
it but between uh see yeah we should
have done that this
year some things have gotten slower
because of Co but the so the 2021 code
24 correct and so this is what I'm
thinking is it
possible not that I want to make this
longer but is it possible to as as this
bill stands is this commission or this
committee is it a
once yes okay is it possible
that we would make this or do you
recommend that we do this just every
time we have to redo the fire codes
we're just going to initiate this
committee or do we want to make this
something that's going to happen the
codes I think something that we can ask
that the committee just to conclude in
its report how do they deal with the
next update okay let's do that let's do
that because I think it's you know
rather because it's not that one of us
might forget or you know just how that
goes represent fellows thank you madam
chair I just wanted to ask you about the
fact that this committee that's proposed
has three senators and three House
Representatives and and I rarely see
that on committies usually it's only one
Senator just can you tell me if that's
unusual or makes sense to
you the it means the Senate is taking it
seriously and it probably means they've
got three volunteers lined
up I mean
that's they
don't three Senators if they don't have
three Senators ready to do the
work
[Music]
followup black
thank you madam chair um am I correcting
my understanding that whatever this um
committee comes up with as as far as
proposal would still go through the
normal process and come to Edna
and and all that oh yes they'll just
have their report will say you know
these are our recommendations and
three4 any other questions or
comments
the
motion I guess I do want to ask this
question uh how as a matter of courtesy
how strongly does representative sh feel
about this because it' be nice to clear
the text but it's if she's really hot
about it I would be in favor of special
ordering in
effect
so that's really my question to her do
you mind if
we well second I just that was not a com
okay I apologize it's a question
sh yes um well I I don't know because as
I said I've been unable to make contact
with my chief uh in my town for these
last uh four days I've been trying um
and I don't know if if he feels that
it's no problem then I would say it's no
problem but if I talk to him this
afternoon or tomorrow and we've already
made this ought to pass and he says oh
no this is a big problem in our town
then I'm going to be
conflicted so I don't know how to answer
your question exactly but like I said I
I just was hoping uh where we didn't act
on it this morning right after the
hearing uh that I could have a chance to
[Music]
way black yeah my only question is um if
we did delay and I was not objecting to
that but if we did
delay
um I don't know what the process is
going to be and when this would actually
go into effect my only concern concern
and maybe it's not an issue is that this
committee if we if we form it has enough
time to to do what's likely to be a
complicated
J I don't know how much delay
to uh well we're going to miss at least
two
weeks probably at Le Pro more likely
three or
four but yes it is going to be a
complicated job and
uh I am I am taking notes on who
expressed interest serving on that
committee because I'm afraid I'm not
question all right in that case the
motion is ought to pass by
representative
leus and the clerk can call the role
yeses no representative
Pearson yes representative yakovich is
not here yes he oh he is
here
yes representative W yes representative
Alro yes representative B yes
representative
lenara
yes representative
no that's a no
represent
no representative
sh um again I just voting no like I said
on that one one section of the
bill well you got to take the whole
[Music]
bab uh representative
Judy not m
j representative Schmid
yes representative Schultz no
representative
um yes representative
groden yes representative O'Brien
no
days all right I I think
that I'm going to hold on to this so
that people could I don't think we
should put this out with a fight when
we're when we're in general agreement on
the bill we merely have a few minor
questions that a couple of people want
to talk about so I will hold on to it
and we can reconsider that motion at our
next executive session or we could just
let it go but I'm I'm not going to to
send it Forward right now I appreciate
that very much Madam fa thank
you
question that my motion would it be
appropriate to retain that bill could we
that I'm having a hard time hearing the
conversation um that was on on which
bills 42 yeah we don't have to vote to
retain it yet we do have I think a month
before we have to vote it out so we all
go talk to our select if there's any and
our researcher is going to check with
the municipal Association and if we
still have questions next time we bring
it up then yes we can retain it then but
I think we can find out a lot in a
couple weeks representative Schulz do
you have a question I do about something
totally different um I
excuse me if it if it's totally
different can we go to the public
right it's being after 2
o'clock I'm opening the public hearing
on the non gerain amendment to House
Bill
141 and I would on repres
representative Pearson who is the
sponsor thank you madam chair thank you
members of Edna committee as discussed
before when we looked at this issue uh
there was a great amount of discussion
regarding
a uh municipality or County's ability to
miraculously erase their pension
debt so in uh in an incredible amount of
very quick work um in attempt to get
this ready for Monday I contacted the
retire
system as well as some other
stakeholders to get their their gist of
of how that should look one of the
things that I've learned being on this
committee is it is always best to make
sure the retirement system is happy with
the language you're about to bring
forward because ultimately they're the
ones that are going to have to interpret
it so in consultation with the New
Hampshire retirement system and in uh
discussions with with Marty Carin with
and subsequently you know members of of
that office they came up with um some
language that was attached to the bottom
of hinal non-gain amendment that
basically just says if you are going to
exempt
your um your county your county or
Municipal chief administrative officer
that you are still going to be required
to pay your portion of the unfunded
liability based on that salary moving
forward until such time is that unfunded
liability
is
exhausted this was this was done
specifically um to try to deal with some
of the questions that were brought up
during the discussion of this in
reference to you know how do
you how do you make how does it how
could a a position like this have its
debt paid off and then moving forward be
you know required to pay debt and what
happens you know one versus the other
and and the complications with that so
the reti system found it would be the
easiest and the fairest to just have
that particular governmental body
continue to pay the unfunded liability
portion only of that position that has
now been removed from the
um basically decertifying the position
position I hope I made that as
complicated as I could thank you
representative Pearson you did an
excellent job there any questions for
representative
pearon representative Shu thank you uh
representative Pearson I I do take
exception
to uh your position that this would be
decertifying that position uh my
understanding is that it would just be
for the time that that individual hold
the addition you're you're correct I
that you are correct that's um that is a
would just be true temporarily yes the
option for for the next person in that
position to be in the retirement system
would exist correct and and I would hope
that uh many people would want to take
advantage of that certainly thank you
thank you for that correction important
because position is still in the
retirement system it's only the indiv
idual person who is not
correct are there is no one else has
signed up is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on this
[Music]
course
representative Schmid did you have a
question for representative Pearson or
for Mr
Carlin I don't know what Mr Carlin is
gonna have to say but there's an issue I
want to I want to make a comment but I
want to hear from
Marty we're working on getting him in so
I thought a brief well then then if if
if we're hung up for a moment I can I
can speak to my concern and and know as
the chairman of Stafford
County delegation I I I know what it
means to have longer serving individuals
in our staffing of the county we have a
County Administrator who is also the
nursing home administrator and he's been
in the position for about 30 years um it
was kind of casually suggested that uh
nobody's Irreplaceable and of course
nobody is
irreplaceable but this gentleman
uh uh is enormously dedicated to our
County and does a phenomenal job I know
what it's like to have somebody who is
excellent uh and how important key
positions are uh those of us who've been
in the house for a while know uh
examples of PE staffers who are maybe
not Irreplaceable but but uh you you
really hate to lose them uh so to the
degree that Marram county has found
somebody that has a pretty solid record
I'll put it that way uh to the idea that
we would might be by doing what we're
thinking of doing that we might cost
them that person's uh you know interest
and and willingness to continue to serve
that is a considerable negative aspect
of the whole situ
I think that's a very comment but it's
more appropriate for an executive
session than I I understand that that's
if we got Marty Carlin Let's us hear
from him Mr Carlin if you would speak to
us uh thank you Madame chair um I just
just wanted to sign on in case anybody
had any questions uh B based on the
public hearing last week and some of the
comments made by members about the
desire to um ensure that the employer
exempting the position still pays
towards the the liability and then in
subsequent conversations with both um
representative Pearson and
representative Shu uh we we looked for
some language that would um you know
that we could administer that would meet
that goal and actually the um assessment
in the uh in the amendment is is similar
to language that was in an unsuccessful
uh bill from several years ago about
retirees working part-time for for
participating employers and at that time
we had done a uh analysis of Legally if
we could um charge the unfunded piece uh
to the employer in these cases and um
you know determine that our
interpretation of the law was that we
could um and we also looked at whether
we
could uh efficiently administer that
that search charge through the current
monthly contribution reporting and we
think you know with some modifications
uh we could we could do that so it
wouldn't produce a typ terribly undue
burden on either the retirement system
or the county or or municipality to um
to to to to contribute so uh I just
wanted to clarify that we we do not have
a position on either the original
Amendment or this one uh you know it's a
policy decision that that um is within
all of your purviews to decide if this
is a sensible course of action but again
just wanted to sign up to kind of state
where we are we where nhrs is with that
and answer any questions if anybody has
Carl seeing none thank you for that
Exposition thank
you stop no place to
go is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on this amendment to House Bill
seeing none I will close the public
hearing
[Music]
motion yes I would like to um move the
amendment
second
you should speak to your
mtion well we uh we did a fairly
exhaustive uh discussion on this both
earlier and today so I I think we're
good
goie I think we've covered everything uh
that needs to be
said is there anyone else who
disagrees and wishes to say something
I'm not
sure thank you madam chair um I will
just state that um the original reason
that I put this in was um for the
administrative officer for Marram County
I have since learned that the county was
afraid that by the time this bill goes
through the process uh the time frame is
going to be beyond what they had hoped
for so they are pursuing some other
means to uh accommodate this employee
and and make it work but I do support
this amendment as a small manner to fix
some of the lack of funding that's going
else
fellows I just have a question um is
there any retroactive aspect to this you
know if there's currently okay it only
applies to contracts entered in after
the effective date of this legislation
you anyone
else right in that case the motion is to
adopt Amendment
141 representative
yeses yes representative Pearson yes
representative
[Music]
squeal
how's your
throne he's muted I don't think he can
unmute himself I don't know well can you
give us a thumbs up or down
something we'll uh we represent yovich
if you could uh work on unmuting
yourself we'll come back to you
representative leus yes representative
Alro yes representative Bailey yes
representative Lara
yes representative Sant
naso
yes representative yes
representative
sh yes representative Judy we
representative Schmid yes representative
Schultz yes representative fellows
yes representative font no
yes representative bro yes
representative o Brian yes and the chair
representative yovich oh yes yovich are
you yes thank
you I vote Yes votes yes 19 to zero on
the
amendment
excent representative Pearson thank you
madam chair then uh I would like to vote
a to pass with Amendment on House Bill
second that's Ron goalie yes Madam
chair excellent do you wish do you wish
to speak to your
motion I do not okay
goie I think enough has been said thank
you very
else
that case the motion is ought to pass
with Amendment
0877 on House Bill 141 and the clerk
will call the RO representative Roy yes
cler yes representative Pi yes
representative yich yes representative
leus yes representative elro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Laro
yes representative
saso yes representative gold yes
Judy representative Schmid yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Fells yes representative
fno yes representative GR yes
representative
O'Brien yes and the chair yes it is the
same 19 Z all right does anyone object
to
consent all right hearing none I'll put
it on
consent and uh Pearson your report at
your very very earliest
convenience and we' like to thank you
all for completing all of our house
bills in a very timely manner and we
actually got two Senate bills as well so
we're way ahead of the
curve we have two sem bills that we've
heard that are we we each need to do
some research so we will get back we're
going to take next week off and then we
have a week with three days of session
and then we'll get back the week after
that so representative
Schulz okay here's my out of left field
uh question or FYI from folks and I
should give you background of why I'm
even asking this um I happen to live
near uh my state representative who
happens to also serve on finance and
apparently they are taking up an
amendment proposed by I think Lyn o
representative obber um that addresses
the same topic that our uh emergency
executive order Bill uh that we
passed um and I thought that was
interesting and I just was curious to
know if anyone had heard of that before
our
vote yeah I don't think anybody
referring to house or House Bill 63 it's
an amendment to I believe it comes into
hb2 no I I understand but is it the
content that was that was in 63 or 417
oh um you know I don't I did hear what
their amendment was but I don't remember
if it mirrored one of the bills we
didn't
pass very well maybe what what I heard
from uh I heard that but I'm not certain
but I heard it was 63 I haven't heard
anything about anything like 417 being
included in
hb2 I just thought it was interesting
given that we literally had just passed
it by almost unanimous consent and um
just that was overhearing this while
visiting neighor who happens to also be
a State
Rep it is not all uncomon for bills that
the house feels the governor or the
Senate might not be happy with to be
included in the budget everybody does it
and so so if if they've decided that U
4117 is important enough to some members
of Finance they'll try and get includ
into the
amendment but it's got to go through
their committee and the house so we'll
see see what comes out of there right
thank you that I just was curious thanks
for uh taking my question I guess it is
thank
you represent Schmidt do you had a
comment uh we had a bill a few minutes
ago uh that where the committee was
basically supportive of the concept but
wanted some additional information if
you recall the the ultimate vote was
like 127 or something like that um and
you said you were going to hang on to
the bill um and I'm just wondering
whether that could potentially get you
or the committee in a little bit of hot
water and if so we could always do
reconsideration right
now and leave it open and then uh and
then vote subsequently on it if that
would potentially alleviate that
potential problem I don't think get me
into trouble representative Schmidt
because it's not up against the deadline
we have plenty of time on that and there
is no necessity to put any house bill
any Senate bills through to the calendar
and I think the staff has enough to do
with the
house representative Schmid it simply
forms okay well I I'm fine with leaving
it the way it is because you're going to
hang on to it uh and uh and the people
who had C questions are going to ask
them maybe they'll get the answers and
then we'll know how to proceed uh next
week I'm completely okay with I already
voted for the
bill just wanted to verify that you do
not need a report for H for 106 until
something
we given could be changes exactly yes
you don't want to write it before you
know if there's an amendment okay want
to make
sure again I am very very pleased that
we've got all the house bills through on
on schedule and uh I will see you all on
8th Joy if the creek don't rise even if
it